one day I was walking home from grocery
shopping with heaps of heavy bags and so
I decided to give some thought to which
way home would be the shortest well the
shortest route would definitely have
been the street diagonally from the
shops to my house but unfortunately no
one had made that path for me instead
there were only paths that went
north-south and east-west surely some of
these paths are better than others I
reasoned because the diagonal line is
the best so routes which are almost
diagonal should be better than going all
the way around right at this point my
brain start to hurt so I forgot all
about this and just trudged back home
the regular way when I got home though I
got interested in this question again
but I decided to make the problem a bit
simpler I want to find the shortest path
between this corner and this corner of
the square but no diagonals are allowed
and the path can only go left or up this
is the longest path and it's two units
long
the would be shortest path is the
diagonals which by trusty Pythagoras is
root two units long let's draw some
other random paths what's the total
distance in the left direction well I
guess it's one unit and the distance in
the up Direction is one unit also making
the total distance too just like the
long way around the same thing is true
for all paths I was completely wrong
there is no shortest path because all
the paths have exactly the same length
to you this is probably like yeah
obviously for me this is still so
surprising let me explain the diagonal
is the shortest route but we can draw
one of our allowed paths that
approximate it you might not think that
this is a particular good approximation
but I can make it better and better and
better until your eyes can't even tell
the difference in fact I could make the
approximation so good someone walking on
it probably couldn't even tell that
they're not quite walking in a straight
line but then they have to be able to
tell because no matter how great the
approximation is these paths all have
length 2 which is way longer than root 2
so this way they'll end up walking so
much extra distance than if they were
actually on the diagonal see that's the
bit that really messes with my head
another weird bit is that in some ways
the sequence is a good approximation
for the line if you know calculus or if
you've seen my last episode you know
that if what we cared about was the area
underneath the diagonal instead of the
diagonals length this staircase shape
has area that gets closer and closer to
the area we want so we have the sequence
of shapes that visually approximate the
line very well and we know it
approximates the area very well too and
yet it's terrible at approximating the
lines lengths this is a really worrying
example how do we know in advance when
an approximation is not going to be good
enough I really don't know so even
though we all use approximations a lot
without a second thought
even approximations that look like
they're really good can go completely
wrong well there are lots of places we
can go from here because this whole
thing brings up heaps of questions one
bit I'm really interested in is the fact
that the shape we were talking about is
actually a fractal fractals in general
are kind of the arch-nemesis of calculus
so we might take up the story from there
next time see you then